so
what about you guys have you guys ever
dated a toxic guy anyone raise your hand
raise your hand you're a razor no kind
of yeah I mean the thing is though when
I look back on it I'm like was it really
toxic or did I just not know myself was
I just not secure in myself
um and I think also the word toxic is
thrown around so much and you know
sometimes when you're talking with your
friends and they're just like oh that's
so toxic but looking back I'm thinking
we were both young he was just doing him
and I was just so like you know I I no I
won't say it was toxic maybe on my
behalf I had an unhealthy attachment but
I I looking back on it I wouldn't say he
was toxic okay so you don't think he was
toxic
okay and what about you Mum was a
hundred thousand percent toxic I just
came for the realization as I was saying
now now though he wasn't toxic
toxic I don't know
um yeah a million percent I think
maybe I was the opposite in my head I
was trying to make it seem like he
wasn't
um and I would always defend him I'd be
out here defend him to everyone my
parents like my whole family my friends
even to him like his family his friends
I'm like no this is the guy for me even
to myself like I become so deluded
because I was so in love but I feel like
again this love bombing phase in the
beginning like maybe I grew attached and
fell in love with someone that doesn't
actually exist
um
but yeah it was just the the regular
things of just being unfaithful maybe he
just couldn't commit and he wasn't the
guy for me but for someone else it may
not be deemed toxic but for me when I'm
with someone I'm very tunnel vision so
if they're not the same like what type
of toxic things did he do
that was a few there was just loads of
messages he would just go hot and cold
like days weeks no communication I was
with him so you were dating him he
didn't talk to you for weeks yep he
would just disappear and be like oh I
just don't want to talk or he sent a
little messages like I just don't want
to talk and I'll be like okay when when
people go through things I'm someone I
give you space I'm not needy I don't
need to be talking to you 24 7 you have
your space but then it become a regular
thing and I was like either there's
something wrong with you or there's
something up here
um and I'm a big Communicator so if you
can't talk to me about stuff fine
whatever but I will try and try and try
it but you know in the end I won't bug
you
um I found condom wrappers and I was
doing the laundry you know being they've
been that good housewife and yeah no it
was just a lot and I'd say it's quite
damaging but at the same time you learn
from it you learn what you don't want
and how old were you guys when you dated
the toxic guy
only recently so in 19 20 21. oh so
you're you're 21 when you dated him okay
that was only like eight months ago okay
and then how many how many years were
you guys with him
together solidly about a year and a bit
and then on and off I'd say two and a
half years two and a half years a year
and a bit a year and a bit but we were
friends for we're like really close
friends for two years before that so
okay and I'm curious did you guys ever
you said you caught him cheating
yes yeah you're not in the ACT but yeah
yeah I'm cheating
I don't think he ever cheated on me but
then I don't know at the same time
anymore there's so much that I just
didn't know
I don't want to get into that okay no no
worries um when you caught him cheating
did you stay or did you leave I left
okay but went back shortly after
I left the house and then went back and
forth and back and forth but yeah it's
not a good cycle to being 100 okay them
would any of you guys be open to dating
a guy
um that it's closed on your end but open
on his or he would sleep with other
girls no no no no no
not that I know about it but you might
you might hail too it depends it depends
yeah okay what about you no no
um so I'm going to tweak it a little bit
okay
um so for me
um it's dating to marriage and it's not
really dating as in a sense of how
you guys would see it it would be we
want to get married he'd be talking to
my mom my dad my brothers getting to
know me with my the male family members
involved
um so I wouldn't uh sorry I forgot the
question
um
I was just asking if you would ever be
open to dating a guy where he's able to
cheat but you're not basically um so we
would be married and if he wanted
another wife where I am now
um with the mindset that I have now
um I wouldn't mind if he had another
wife but this is not another wife this
is being unfaithful but but I I'm not I
don't date men yeah so do you see what
I'm so that's why I said the tweaking I
don't like I don't have a boyfriend and
I won't have a boyfriend because I'm a
Muslim woman we don't oh you know that's
yeah that's strictly forbidden
um so would you be okay with your
husband sleeping around with loads of
different women then I guess that's the
Tweet not necessarily having one wife it
would be sleeping with those of other
women
but no she said that what she'd be happy
with her husband having another wife
yeah yeah not a side piece yeah yeah so
but you'd be okay with 2y who would be
okay with a second wife anyone anyway no
no no do you know what she's like yeah I
think she does everything it's at the
bedroom I'll be happy
um so you said no hell no and what about
if it was just like casual stuff and
then you're the main girl no why why are
you ranking who's casual in here yeah
yeah either one or none simple I thought
I'd become normalized too normalize like
people who believe in polygamy need to
stay with them people they can't try and
convert the people who want monogamy in
life but they do and that's where this
toxic stuff happens yeah yeah
I agree with that all right auntie
oh can you tell the story about when you
caught the guy cheating anyone in the
bedroom yeah oh exactly oh yeah
um I've seen this guy for a long while
and he's supposed to take me shopping he
didn't turn up so I went to his house
but we used to hang out with all of his
friends that was one of the guys and
then this lovely young lady I found her
I said hi
and I asked where he was and she knew me
because she's always upstairs I went
upstairs
and he just sort of like she climbs into
bed and he was just
and I was like and you can see him
trying to you're already in bed of her
yeah I've seen trying to distance
himself and I said to her
is that your man
she says yeah I said hug him up we don't
matter whoever's there you hug him up
and she's like I said hug him harder
it's gonna be like a cup of coffee
I said yes please and she wouldn't
answer it and he said that's what you
want me to say
what do you want me to do because I'm
not going to hit her do you want me to
knock you out I said I don't want to
scream and shout I'm just gonna sit here
I think I had lunch as well yeah
I ended up being her friend because I
would hang out with all the guys and all
the guys was like no when did you tell
her did you tell her she must be known
that she's watching this
I didn't tell her I was a friend he's a
player I played at my Mom's party yes I
said you come in she said no he didn't
invite me I said you come
how long does this go on for
until they split up until oh stop yeah
you stopped anything with him oh no
straight away yeah I started but it was
just fun to go there I used to go there
when he wasn't there she goes oh he's
coming home soon you know I'm just
popping out to the shop so I watch
dinner and I thought this is what you're
having for dinner
yeah tormented yeah but I was nice about
it and I did disrespect her
you know and then one day he turned up
and his whole car was covered in white
paint I was just like oh dear what did
you do as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible